las escenas de violencia social son muy
infrecuentes en China cientos de
trabajadores en chinchó la capital
provincial de henan se han enfrentado
esta mañana a policías y funcionarios
armados con piedras y con palos también
han destrozado cámaras de vigilancia
ventanas y otro mobiliario urbano la
fábrica afectada es de foxcon la
multinacional taiwanesa que es también
la principal suministradora de Apple esa
misma fábrica conocida como ciudad
iPhone porque ahí trabajan 200.000
empleados ya ocupó las portadas globales
el mes pasado cuando después de
descubrirse unos cuantos casos muchos
empleados huyeron a la carrera para
evitar un confinamiento inminente la
empresa para retener a los trabajadores
que quedaban y para fichar a nuevos
prometió espectaculares aumentos
salariales y bonificaciones la razón de
las protestas actuales Es que la empresa
no habría cumplido con esas promesas
además los empleados también lamentan la
escasa comida y otras las condiciones
duras del confinamiento chenchou ha
estado lidiando durante meses con un
brote que hace ya semanas afectó a la
fábrica de iPhone la fábrica para evitar
la paralización de la producción
estableció un sistema de burbuja que la
mantiene aislada del mundo sostienen los
expertos que apenas ha podido mitigar el
problema que la producción se ha
reducido en un 30% de hecho Apple ya ha
advertido a sus usuarios de que tendrán
que esperar más de lo previsto por sus
nuevos teléfonos